en cette période de crise avec la
fermeture des cantines des restaurants
et de fait que les français restent
toute la journée chez eux
les supermarchés sont les derniers
endroits pris littéralement d'assaut
ainsi deux grandes tendances se dégagent
une pénurie sur certains articles mais
aussi une flambée des prix due à l'offre
et la demande dans certaines grandes
surfaces on peut trouver des choux
fleurs à plus de 5 euros les poireaux
ont doublé prix quant aux fraises
elle coûte 70 % plus cher qu'il ya
quelques semaines même chose sur le lait
dans certains points de vente des
augmentations du également en partie aux
problèmes d'exportation de certains pays
autre explication face à l'afflux massif
de clients les enseignes applique
beaucoup moins de promotions si
certaines ont décidé de bloquer les prix
sur certains produits
cette crise est une manne financière
inespérée pour les professionnels du
secteur
alors selon vous les supermarchés
profitent ils de la crise du coronavirus
alors c'est vrai que c'est ce qu'on
entend énormément et ça chez christian
quesada il aura 20 jours pour faire
appel
parce que c'est doublé pendant les
périodes de confinement alors est-ce que
les supermarchés
voilà font exprès de faire flamber les
prix et profite de la cré du canda virus
matthieu delormeau
oui elle aurait dit deux choses qui est
insupportable disent que souvent ils ont
du mal à se ravitailler ce qui aidera
plupart du temps est faux et ce qu'ils
lisent aussi pour se défendre
ils disent non mais en fait les gens
achètent différents produits et font des
courses différemment
c'est totalement faux a pas nié égal il
a été constaté qu'il ya plus de 20% de 2
d'augmentation
un exemple ils font une salade de mâche
est passé de 6 euros à 11 euros
et ça c'est cette ses torts et parce que
pour la plupart des gens qui ne peuvent
pas sortir à plus d'un kilomètre de chez
eux ils ne peuvent même pas aller dans
des supermarchés ou de données par
marché gigantesque qui sont plus loin et
son envie d'aller dans les supérettes en
bas de chez eux les carrefours site il
surprit tout ça et se font massacrer
parce que les gens savent qu'ils ne
peuvent pas sortir de leur quartier
vraiment c'est une honte de faire de
l'argent comme ça sur un virus et sur
des gens qui sont confinés
gilles verdez alors je ne suis pas du
tout d'accord moi je fais mes courses
une fois par semaine dans une supérette
de quartier et je prends les relevés des
prix
il ya quelques denrées fruits et légumes
qui flambent les endives sont passés de
2 à 4 euros les carottes c'est une
flambée des prix
mais c'est aussi parce qu et comment sur
les navets
[Rires]
c'est des relevés concret et pourquoi ça
augmente aussi
c'est parce qu'on importe plus d'espagne
ou d'italie est donc bien sûr nos
producteurs et c'est un peu plus cher ça
c'est bien seulement
donc c'est ma lien des augmentations
mais on achète français il faut que ça
c'est pas gentil quand on pense à ses
directeurs j'en saurai n'est qu'en ce
moment les gens se ruiner non mais oui
ton panier
mathieu mathieu de balle ils augmentent
et on doit lutter en ce moment on doit
faire travailler des agriculteurs en ce
moment c'est très important on leur fait
de gros bisous géraldine maillet non
lâche absolument pas d'accord avec
mathieu et je suis complètement d'accord
avec gilles moi aussi j'ai constaté ça
effectivement le concombre aujourd'hui
n'est plus aux landais il est français
il a été multiplié par trois et le
concours français est magnifique et les
français dans les chairs et la fraise la
fraise française la garriguette est
beaucoup plus cher aussi que la fraise
espagnole sanguine au coût de production
dont +10 en confort et et non on s'en
fout pas et en plus je trouve que c'est
très très facile aujourd'hui de tomber
sur la grande distribution
dieu sait qu'ils ont souvent leurs torts
mais là ils ont ils lancent plein
d'action solidaire pour soutenir les
soignants ils font plein de choses et je
trouve que voilà aujourd'hui ils font ce
qu'ils peuvent
et surtout ça se maintient moi je galère
mais différemment on y va mine de rien
il va falloir trouver il va falloir
trouver une régulation après mais il
faut faire travailler nos producteurs
français a présenté à trouver une
régulation parce que peut-être que si on
les fait plus travailler
peut-être qu'ils seront plus de
productivité ils auront plus de produire
avec le dp pour produire moins cher et
les prix vont baisser
donc c'est très important cette première
étape c'est vrai que c'est une première
étape qui est compliqué mais mine de
rien si derrière ils peuvent produire
plus et donc produire au même prix que
les autres ça serait exceptionnel rené
malleville oui décollage à marseille il
ya pas de d'épicerie de proximité
malheureusement et où chaque fois je
prends la voiture mais je vais quand
même chez le boucher eu de particulier
chez un boulanger particulier et là je
suis content il est dans mon village
depuis le 10 mars
je me suis allé quand supermarché de
villefranche du lauragais ya quelques
kilomètres
tu sais pourquoi pour acheter des
groupes pro b zone les bons la vie
heed a décrié de mowgli lable salles sur
l'hers à bambous léger de staël et
solaire à la presse de salaire ou gucci
sélection r je trouve anormal que les
gens mais tonnage sommes bien contents
de rencontrer le petit commerce de
proximité et j'espère qu'ils se
rappelleront après ça que le petit
commerce de proximité
il est ici le clip on va bien sûr bébés
ayant conduit que dans les supermarchés
mais il faut pas déconner cyril m
monsieur castaldi jeunes s'épanouissent
dans juste quand même et je suis
d'accord avec géraldine ce que j'ai vu
un sujet ce matin les pâtes le riz de
chasser bull c'est moins cher qu'avant
ils ont baissé leurs prix pour le coup
là on l'on peut on leur tape souvent sur
le dos mais j'ai l'impression que sur ce
coup là mais les iep aix terrain ont
fait un geste lourd de la population
honnêtement mathieu claude jeu mais
évidemment que je veux pour de protéger
des producteurs français et la france
m'enfin c'est pas le moment en ce moment
on est en train demander aux gens un de
se confiner 2 une personne sur quatre
est au chômage
toutes les ppe sont en train de crever
de faim en train de fermer c'est
hallucinant et vous allez demander aux
gens maintenant qu'ils sont chez eux
confiné qui crèvent de faim qui n'ont
plus un euro d'aller en ce moment en
plus régler le problème les producteurs
français
maintenant on demande à aider les gens a
explosé alors mais mathieu laveau
bertrand gille je fais systématiquement
les mêmes cours je prends les mêmes
choses du jambon sous vide du machin
pardon c'est pas top et je prends ça et
j'ai constaté que mon panier ils
augmentaient systématiquement de 20
euros arrêté ne parler que des fruits et
légumes c'est faux mais parce que nous
parce que vous en prenez plus mathieu
moi aussi mon panier moyen il augmente
mais quand vous prenez les pourcentages
d'augmentation de la consommation c'est
énorme mais moyenne institution je
voudrais saluer c'est la direction de la
concurrence et des fraudes dgccrf
il passe partout pour empêcher que ça
mais j'ai su qu'il sert il gilles
apparemment il a un copain là bas et on
s'est bien repris ce que tu oublié ce
qu'il oublie le livre tous c'est que
quelques liban au supermarché il te pas
des conneries qu'ils n'ont pas voté
si tu vois ton d'épicier du créa le
boucher du coin tu prends ce qui te
connaît mais que tu es haha tu pars cela
tu ne veux pas d as tu pas cela tu me le
palier à la sortie qu'à dépasser bout
n'hésitez kayser j'étais mamad des
magasins de proximité
mais c'est nous dire à gilles il nous
dira gilles commander sur l'aubergine
justement avant le sondage dette effet
garé juste appelé je vous montrer
comment est arrivée le patient zéro en
france du corps d'un virus 86 % sont de
l'avis de mathieu
ils pensent les meilleurs marchés
profitent de la crise du coronavirus
mathieu je voulais ajouter quelque chose
là dessus mais c'est vrai que kameni
parce que les gens sont cp dit de vous
entendre
moi je lis partout partout sur instagram
je reçois plein de messages ou les gens
disent à panier égal on se fait
massacrer donc arriver en départementale
en techniques et légaux là mais
j'entends même et achètent des choses
différentes tâches est plus des gens ne
sont pas débiles je vous dis à panier
moyen ça a été constaté par plein de
statistiques s'est écrasé sur internet
regarder
oui les prix ont flambé et pas que les
fruits et légumes donc on parle pas que
les producteurs
on parle de petits magasins ou de
supérettes de ce que tu veux qu'ils ont
compris qu'on ne pouvait pas sortir de
notre quartier et que du coup ils sont
on est pris on est pris en otage c'est
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre mot voilà avec
une sorte de 2e ou il ya raymond ya
raymond qui nous dit mon raymond les
prix n'augmentent pas si les fraises
gariguettes 20 euros le kilo voilà donc
merci au monde voilà